[Music]
in my nerd World addiction was first
forever was a considered a moral failure
it's just cuz you're weak Y and then I
got my own opinions why they shifted it
to it's a disease yeah and now there's a
growing conversation like a consensus
behind closed doors if you will there's
a few people saying that out loud that
addiction is actually probably your body
work pretty good it is doing what works
to get through either some trauma or
some chaos or pretty messy situation
where have you heard that that's I heard
that like in the in the in the closed
like behind closed Doh circle like at
rehab that's that's nerd talk it's ND
talk it's maybe it's a little like I
remember there was a girl in rehab that
was there was uh like I'm going to say
in high school like just molested just
by her somebody that lived with her yeah
and she discovered alcohol MH and
alcohol worked saved her life that's
right and that's a that's a to hear that
is anyone listening to this to hear that
you go that is a that's hard that's you
never even had heard a thought like that
that's I go where did you hear that
because I've heard that in the very
closed doors of like treatment centers I
didn't know that was like I've told
College parents like like what my kids
doing drugs like cuz it works cocaine
works it's it'll kill you yes but it
works it it is the only so if you go if
you go and I've been here before you go
I cannot I thought not true but I cannot
after the the glory or height of this
comedy show everybody you know signing
autographs everything this is
unbelievable I cannot survive the night
in this hotel room I felt like closing
that hotel door was like a prison cell
yes without my cell phone or uh in some
kind of relationship [__] flirty type
situation or alcohol I will not survive
correct now that's not true right but
your chest tightens up it closes in and
so these
these mechanisms prevented me from
jumping out the window that's right and
now the the the the demons were just
screaming so loudly right that I that
those now a therapist would obviously
say long term this is obviously going to
have a lot of but it's not it is you
go you see somebody out on Broadway
drinking drunk or whatever that you want
to judge them or you want to you go
whatever his present situation is
everybody has a set of tools MH to cope
with them yeah and this is the one this
is the card he knows how to play that's
right getting drunk and it's and long
term it's going to be has consequences
but this is the only one that might be
keeping him on the planet now you got to
give him another card I'm going to be
about time this comes out I'll be silver
four years D congrats thank you man
there's another there's another I found
another card that kind of Trumps that
car you can't just take that card away
it's a great thing don't take away
somebody who just had surgery don't take
away the crutches without giving him
something else pay medication yeah at
the beginning now now long yeah you
go now we get now somebody goes hey I've
been sober for 3 weeks then I went back
and then I've been sober for a month and
I I've relapsed I was like yeah that's
how that's somebody learning getting off
crutches yeah yeah why are we crushing
the guy for oh yeah that was a big shift
it about a decade ago and I used to ask
college students like why are you doing
this yeah and the question switch to to
what happened yeah in your world that
this is the best way you bodies figured
out how to get through the day yeah that
changes the question because that's
one's super compassionate empathetic
let's figure this out and one is when
you get your crap together then you come
back in the house and that's yeah was
out of like a it was over it was over
everything yeah and you were raised the
same as I was they they meant well your
parents meant well so did mine and I
don't like a lot of the deconstruction
and like to stop everybody doing they
had they had only their tools yeah right
they had their tools and if you go back
to them that who like I go who are you
mad at because you go back to your youth
pastor he would be embarrassed too of
course he would be like yeah sorry yeah
I didn't I I did the best I could with
what I had yes so you go I don't know
like yeah do actions have consequences
sure no nobody nobody's saying that it
wasn't when I was in in rehab in in uh
that there was
no he couldn't do nothing out there
obviously everything was taken away and
then I remember and I didn't even have
any knowledge of this prior to going in
but I was like you know alcohol and I
wasn't and then everything was taken
away and I go I I don't know I don't
think I have any addictions I'm fine
with I'm not you know itching or I go I
don't know I'm pretty good and then I
remember it was family week and
everybody's kind of family people's
wives would come to visit them and then
this other guy in treatment center his
wife came and then we were in the
cafeteria I don't know where some she
walked by and goes He I just want to let
you know like I'm a big fan and it like
oh dude yeah it was I was like oh this
is my addiction it she goes I just want
to let you know like your stuff is so
hilarious and I go oh I'm back yeah or
whatever the you know and it was like oh
that's and that's what I if I ever talk
about it it's like I'm fighting that
gotcha once you get some privileges you
go out and like you can go to dinner
with with amongst supervision or you can
go in rehab and you can get your phone
back and you get your car and then it
loosens up as you prove yourself to be
trustworthy and uh I remember one time
the guys go we're just going to order in
food tonight we're not and I was so
bummed this is the beginning of my
recovery like oh cuz when I went out
people said hey John what up to see and
I was like and that's what I fight then
and currently okay so that's that's
similar to like if you have a cocaine
addiction yeah you
can cre construct a life where you're
just not there it's you're not around it
it's possible if you struggle with the
sorder of eating yeah you have a
different level of work because you have
to make peace because you can't do life
without food sex too sex too that's
right intimacy connection all that you
have to make peace with it yeah in a you
have to do it like if you're are you
drinking or not drinking doesn't matter
there's the
firm yes and like or workaholism or
narcissism you have to work yeah and
there a lot of these quote addictions or
struggles and by the way everybody's
listening is probably like okay if you
if you work in construction and you have
a lunch break and you go buy three
double cheeseburgers crush them with a
Coke and go back to Landscaping nobody's
goingon to nope call you on that NOP but
if you have a if you're sad and uh maybe
you're you got dumped and you go I'm
feeling bummed out and you go down and
you three cheese cheesburgers and crush
them right we may be having a different
conversation right so what is the
so your your workaholism sex eating all
these things that you have to do what is
your body trying to but but when it
becomes the way you pacify yourself from
deal with life could go I could go on a
standup there's like a whole range of
like people email me all the time and be
like uh I struggle with depression
comedy lifting my spirits I'm going
through a medical somebody said like I'm
I'm in the in the operating room when I
get out of my chemo I watch your videos
it's like oh my gosh and then there's
this
monster over here that wants attention
and wants uh accolades and affirmation
for my insecurities and I could be
all on this range of course and you're
like do I love stand up and do I love
helping people yes yes
also does the same activity
can it be expressed as very negative or
like acting out of my insecurities or
pain yes the only way I've seen it work
though is I think a lot for years we
spent time trying to solve that that
Continuum instead of healing from the
bottom up yeah being and if if my body's
not trying to hide from my own life from
from me yeah then I can have I can have
a couple pieces of candy and I don't
have to Mainline the bag I told my
girlfriend I go
hey I need to go to the NASCAR Awards
just to make sure like just to you know
to introduce myself she goes BS it's
actually more beneficial as a comedian
to be amongst the people I need to be in
the grand stands not in the suite yep
and so she goes if you want to go and
get your ego stroked I'll go with you
and then we went we both agreed on that
we had a great time yes just say they go
that's fine cuz you're human human me
too y yeah she goes and I'd like to go
rent a dress and get all my makeup done
I'd like to go but don't say we're not
doing what we're doing here so where
does that shame come from that that
secret like I got to hold that I got to
create a narrative around this and most
of us do that I think without even
thinking about it I got to stay a little
bit later I got to stay a little bit
later work a little bit later work
actually don't you are uncomfortable
being in the presence of your wife and
your kids because you don't know what
you're doing and so you feel your body
feels safer at work and you're and
you're you're you're pretty good at work
a king here you're pretty good at work a
king you're pretty good here that's
right so why would why would anyone be
it verbalizing that and then it comes
down to that shame your buddy sat down
with you and told you exactly this you
go yeah dude like go to the thing and
have the time of your life I get it or
he's like hey I'm struggling to be
president home cuz at work everybody
needs me whenever I'm there I am a king
and when I'm home my wife's like you
need to take out the track ex exactly
and you go what if you told if you sat
there and told me that I would go yeah I
get it how would you respond with
anything else but that or they tell you
when you have kids everything's
wonderful and they don't tell you it's
real boring or it's just you're sitting
in the the you're sitting at the track
meet for six hours and they haven't even
run and it's hot and and you watch some
K do high jump and everyone's clapping
and it it's yeah it's not that yeah it
comes down to that what's what do I
think is going to actually happen if I
say this out loud am I going to lose
everything I'm going to lose my wife I'm
going to lose my family I'm going to
lose my identity and then you talk to
people who like no I lost it I lost it
yeah I lost all yeah you had to The Only
Way Forward is to give up was to make
pieace that it all is gone yeah yeah
like dude I remember we would go to this
like uh we would do ecoin therapy every
Thursday you would go off campus you get
in this van and go off and we dude I'm
not lying and the food and there the
funny thing about uh rehab if it anybody
that's going to like Malibu and has
massages and that's not rehab that's not
re re this place there's no women there
there's no drugs alcohol no cell phones
no screens no movies uh no caffeine no
sugar no fiction books no even if you
like to get a runner's Hive for
exercising then you could just walk so
anything that would allow you to escape
gone yeah anything gone and so you and
and it does
reset your Baseline I was like man if I
could go swing a golf club
MH be euphoric right oh my goodness if I
would if I could go see my nephew which
as an addict or alcoholic you don't you
want to have anything to do with if I
could go sit and watch a baseball game
yeah a high school
b te- game you You' be like this is
incredible and we would drive past this
McDonald's and I would go I would
give anything to to be in there yeah to
go sink my teeth and do a double we
talked about double cheeseburgers twice
already and the definition of addiction
by the way is as simple as you can Poss
we put it repeated attempts to quit
despite Mountain consequences so if you
have a drink and you never you never
you're providing for your family you're
still present you're that's not an
addiction if you're getting a double
cheeseburger like we we went up to the
Kentucky to keeland the other day and
and we gambled on the horse racing I
don't it didn't I don't want to go back
I don't want to secretly sure I it I
don't know downloading whatever on yeah
and I and I and I lost 100 bucks yeah it
is that I'm not saying I'm crushing it
but that isn't right they go any
therapist or any anybody go okay and if
you go no more gambling I go okay yeah
yeah I it
doesn't grip me
right